hi guys sci-fi recap here before we
start
warning spoilers ahead today
i'm going to explain a thriller and
science fiction movie called iboy
there is a young boy named tom tom has a
childhood friend named danny
at school tom coverly likes a girl named
lucy
they meet each other after school to
discuss their homework a bad boy
named eugene suddenly comes to bother
their conversation
at home tom lives with his grandmother
named nan
that night tom intends to meet lucy at
her house
her door was unlocked he immediately
goes inside to check on lucy
apparently four criminals had just raped
her and one of them had filmed the scene
after tom sees the incident he
immediately runs away and tries to call
the police
when his phone is connected he is shot
right in his head
after that night tom wakes up in the
hospital after being in a coma for 10
days
he sees his grandmother taking care of
him then the doctor explains tom's
condition
actually there were fragments from the
cell phone that entered his brain
the fragments entered along with the
bullet that hit his head the doctor
explains that he couldn't remove the
fragment 100
because it is too risky for his brain
cells the doctor tells him to come back
in case something strange happened to
him
at home tom begins to feel something
unusual
now he is able to listen to
conversations from other people's
electronic devices very clearly
transmission of digital data traffic can
also be seen by him due to the cell
phone fragments that have been fused
with his brain
it's as if he has access to data servers
all over the world
he can retrieve any data digitally
without using any electronic device
everything he needs is already in his
brain tom returns to visit lucy to
apologize to her after a long time they
haven't seen each other
he regrets that he couldn't do much to
protect lucy that night however
she understands it and she hopes that
everything will get better as usual
on the way home tom listens again to all
conversations that occur on electronic
devices
around him at one point he becomes very
confused because of things he had never
seen or heard before
and finally he passed out the next day
tom wakes up from his stupor
he plans to return to school after his
surgery break
he meets danny at school and tells him
that he suspects eugene of his
involvement at lucy's house incident
that night
he says that eugene's cell phone was
connected to lucy's wi-fi right at that
time of the incident
but danny is still not convinced by his
current statement
back to the class tom intentionally
checks the data transmission from all
his friends cell phones
he chooses to focus on spying eugene's
cell phone he is very surprised when he
finds a video of lucy being raped that
night from this point on
he's getting more convinced by his
suspicions of eugene with his superpower
he instantly creates a little explosion
on eugene's cell phone eugene gets
shocked and the others laugh at him
that night he goes to a party to spy on
eugene and his men
now he knows that eugene's gang consists
of four people
eugene is the leader of the gang then he
directly walked over to eugene
luckily there is dany who stops tom and
eugene from attacking each other
he leads tom out of the party for the
last time tom tells him that eugene was
the perpetrator of lucy's incident
but sadly he still denies tom's
statement tom returns to visit lucy to
cheer her up
from upstairs they see eugene and his
man laughing innocently he sees lucy's
expression immediately turned sad
which means she actually knew the
perpetrator was eugene unknown messages
begin to be sent to eugene as the
beginning of tom's revenge
from his bed tom learns how to hack a
system using his superpower
he stealthily terrorizes eugene and his
man after mastering the technique last
night
their cell phones are hacked by him so
he could see all the activities they are
doing
at the same night tom starts his hacking
action from turning off the lights in
their house
until he accidentally records one of
eugene's friend named cass
masturbating during a presentation at
his school tom hacks the laptop used by
his teacher
he presents the video about cast
masturbating in his room making all
students laugh
and cass who watches the video too feels
very embarrassed about it
after school tom tells the latest story
to lucy who had not been to school for a
long time
she is very entertained by the story
along with tom who secretly sends a
message to lucy
he uses the alias i boy in the message
in order not to be known by others
including lucy as they make their way
back from the riverbank
unexpectedly eugene and his men confront
them eugene thinks that the two of them
had been terrorizing them all along
when eugene wants to beat him up he
immediately sends an unknown message to
them that they are targeting the wrong
person
they are confused and look around for
who is the center of the message so tom
and lucy get a chance to escape from
them
after they searched around and couldn't
find the sender of the message they
intend to steal a car on the side of the
road
when they managed to get into the car
suddenly the car was locked
automatically and could not be open from
inside
this can happen because of tom who has
hacked the car system from afar
he threatens eugene and his man over the
radio in the car he asks why they attack
lucy's family
while making the car full of smoke he
intentionally tries to scare them even
more by casting fire on the car
because cass is so scared he reveals
that they were ordered by someone named
cuts
after tom gets the answer he lets them
go and soon the car explodes
after getting information about cuts he
goes to cuts his house for revenge
surprisingly danny is also in the
residence
the television which cuts and his
friends are watching is hacked by tom
then he plays a video that cuts his car
has been peed on
cuts is very surprised and he
immediately goes with his friend to
check the condition of his car
tom goes inside cuts his house after
they came out he destroyed all the
electronic devices inside the house
using his superpower
coincidentally he also finds cuts cuts's
drug storage box and takes cuts as drugs
with him
with the drugs he has a brilliant plan
he puts cuts his drugs into many small
packages and puts them where eugene and
his men live
and then he hacks into the police
station to report eugene and his men
that they are involved in drugs industry
with the evidence that tom had
previously placed the next day eugene
and his men are arrested by the police
along with the evidence
meanwhile cuts his bank account is also
hacked by tom
making his bank balance runs out the
next night tom quietly listens to cuts
on the phone with his boss
named elman elman gives cuts a final
warning to find out who's messing up
their activities
from the top of a building tom tracks
ellen's whereabouts right away
but he doesn't find any information
about elman like something was
protecting him
at the same time cuts orders his
remaining men to find the location of
iboy by confiscating all electronic
devices in the area
nevertheless they still don't know that
tom doesn't need any hacking tools
the next day he catches a signal of a
drug deal between cuts and element after
he finishes his exam
he plans to thwart the transaction at
night by burning all the drugs
tom's grandmother who is worried about
tom's behavior changed meets dany and
asks for his help to look after tom
denny agreed to help meanwhile tom
remains to follow cutz's car
unfortunately he loses track of cuts in
the middle of the trip because cuts had
thrown his cell phone in a random trash
can
with an amazing idea from tom he hacks a
satellite to track down cuts his vehicle
and finally finds it
he resumes his journey to their base tom
sees a lot of people guarding the place
he learns martial arts the moment he
sneaks into the place
with his new knowledge he can paralyze
one of the guards there
then he directly sets fire to drugs
located not far from his location
when he wants to leave the place
unexpectedly cuts and his men appear and
beat tom until he almost dies
in an urgent situation he attempts to
make high-frequency sounds with his
superpower that can interfere with
everybody's hearing
that way he can escape safely from that
place tom wakes up in an isolated spot
by the river
in the meantime lucy is still waiting
for him at school because the previous
day they had promised to take the exam
together
by the time tom arrives at the school
the exam is over
lucy is disappointed with him outside
the school they are very surprised to
see cass's corpse hanging above
danny meets with tom to see how he's
doing then tom asks danny who is cast
killer
he replies that it's probably our boy
responsibility
since then tom feels all the problems
caused by him and his superpower
he returns to the doctor who had
operated on his head asking to remove
the remaining cell phone fragments that
were still in his brain
the doctor refuses because the cell
phone fragments were embedded deep in
tom's brain
in other words removing it is the same
as killing tom he returns home regretful
and guilty for all of this
when he enters the house elman is
waiting inside with his man pointing a
gun at tom's head
tom's grandmother also becomes a hostage
for them
all this time elman had known that the
person using the alias i boy was tom
not only that hellman also knows tom's
superpower is hacking without using
electronic devices
turns out he got all the information
from danny who had been watching tom all
this time
danny is willing to tell the information
for money ellman commands tom to hack
into the bank system where the money
could be transferred to his bank account
at first tom refuses to do it but ellen
has caught lucy at the warehouse and
threatens to kill her if tom doesn't
obey his orders
in the end tom chooses to comply with
him he starts hacking into the bank
system and slowly filling the money into
elman's bank account
unbeknownst to anyone tom hacks into
eugene's cell phone to call the police
after a while the police come to the
warehouse to search the area
however eugene and his men manage to
escape the search
lucy who sees a gun on the floor
instantly takes it and points the gun at
eugene and his men
this time she manages to escape with
eugene's gun
when she wants to leave the place she
encounters elman who is carrying tom
eventually she returns to being a
hostage and hellman commands tom again
to start filling the money into his bank
account
in that situation tom tries to save
himself and lucy by hacking their cell
phone until it explodes
tom is able to get out but suddenly he
is hit by elman from behind using an
iron pipe
elman wants to kill tom straightaway
because he is so pissed off at the right
time lucy appears with a gun and shoots
almond in the hand because he still has
some energy
he hits back at lucy tom who sees the
fight becomes very angry so he takes out
the rest of his power by gathering shock
waves and throws them at elman until he
dies with it
after that night tom returns to a coma
and regains consciousness after a few
days
he is accompanied by his grandmother in
the hospital things start to get better
since elman died
now the area where tom lives is peaceful
and there is no more crime going on
danny who has betrayed tom wants to say
sorry by giving tom the money he
received from elman earlier
tom refuses the money and says that not
everything can be paid for with money
it is revealed that danny was the one
who recorded the video that night
definitely their friendship will never
be the same as before
in the meantime tom and lucy start their
first date
they can regain their calmness and now
lucy knows that our boy is tom
his superpower to hack is still there
which he can use to do good things
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out
thank you for watching